In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful, Omar Mohsen,
how can you scan your file to
make sure that it has a virus or not in less
than a minute? Without having an antivirus, we will go
to the VirusTotal website and find the
site opening for us in this way. We will choose a file
and go to the checkfile.  Or choose the location of the
file in which you suspect that there is a
problem, or it may be in a file or not. We will make a
choice file. I posted files for you
like this. One of my colleagues was looking for crack 2010, so I wanted to download it from the Internet as a compressed file in this form and create a scan for it in front of you.  And we will see what the result will
be. As soon as he chooses the file
to do a scan, he will begin to create an upload on the
Internet to do a scan. He tells me
that this file has a scan for 19 minutes, so this is a good thing.
If someone had done a scan before,
we would tell him and show me what his results were
after.  I didn't go in to see what his results were
and I noticed that all of these are anti-virus companies. Anti-
virus companies are telling me that this virus contains Torjan
and Bay, and of course, as we see, all of these are
possible types of viruses that are present in this
file. This is the first site. The second site
is called Yers Sanji.  Dot org also had the same
issue. I made a choice file and I would choose. I was also
home to a crack again, as we see. After I
worked on housing, we noticed that companies say that
it does not contain viruses, and there are companies that also say
that it contains viruses, which are in red.
Of course, my advice to you is mostly if  You have a
program that needs to be activated or you need a crack,
as they say, do not try if you are using the program
Dot and try to see why there is an alternative, meaning that you either buy the program Dot and it will
be something
very good, thank you. I mean, in appreciation of the
programmers’ code in the program or if you do not
have it or  Your circumstances do not allow you to try to find an alternative. Why do
you mean, for example, you have a program to decompress
WinRAR? You can find an alternative in it called P1. This is a
very good and free alternative. People recommend it
and use it, and there is no problem without paying a penny. There is also
another program called Internet
Down Manager. A lot of people are looking for it.  In order for God to show the
sign of downloading and all this talk,
you can also download an alternative called AgeGate.
Thus, if you search for many programs, you will find
alternatives to them. You do not need to download the same program and
search for a crack and leave your device with
viruses. Mostly, these viruses are created,
meaning no one can do them.  Something for free. I mean, even the
one who makes a crack or
makes the serial, for example, what is in the keygen
or something you find, I prepared for you a virus so that he can
benefit in one way or another. Thank you, and I am sorry if it took a
long time. Don’t forget to subscribe to
the channel and like and share so that everyone
can benefit.